everyone for sticking around and thanks
to the organizers for having me or it's
nice to see many of you for many years
this is a problem I worked on when I was
a postdoc with Danvers Field in UC Davis
think about 93 or so and I started
working on it again recently and the
reason I worked on it again is because
it involved converting a combinatorial
result to an LP rounding result so
that's what I want to tell you about the
this is the main message of the talk I'm
going to tell you about minimum poised
trees and I define poised of a tree in
an undirected graph as the sum of the
diameter of the tree and the maximum
degree of any node in the tree that's
what the poise of a tree is long time
ago I gave a log in approximation for
the poise of a tree and I'm going to
describe that approximation algorithm
for you and recently I wanted to find an
LP rounding algorithm for the same
problem okay and I'm going to show you
how I was recently able to do that with
my co-authors who I should mention my
brilliant grad student Jenny who just
started this week at vamo and colleagues
at Northeastern Raj Mohan and Ravi
syndrome and then I'll in the end I
think I'll definitely have time this is
a really simple talk I'll tell you how I
got to this problem at all from some
problems and rumor spreading all right
so before we get started
what if I gave you a graph a complete
graph and I asked you to minimize the
diameter of a tree what's the best tree
right yeah if I gave you a complete
graph and I asked you to minimize the
the degree of the tree what's the best
tree it's a path so what is the solution
for the minimum points
I'll give you a complete graph I want
you to find a tree of minimum boys
what'll it be it's a path of stars no
can do better may be log n over log log
n great so basically it's a tree where
the the diameter is roughly equal to the
degree so it's actually a a complete
diri tree of depth D right so you sort
of balance the diameter and the degree
and you get log n over log log n because
D to the D is about n I just want to
fill the nodes of the tree okay so
that's that's the kind of thing I'm
looking for okay all right
okay so we got that so this is the this
is the outline of my talk I'm going to
give you that first log in approximation
by taking a detour to some slides I had
from 10 years ago and then I'm going to
repurpose the same slides to show you
the lp rounding and I'm going to use
even older slides to show you the
application of this thing so that's the
three parts to my talk okay so actually
if you don't remember anything from this
talk this is really nice trick and this
trick will remind you of the gulp the
freeze gobbly RT ma fury solution for a
TSP that lotzie mentioned and many other
things that happened today so it's a
very simple idea for building spanning
trees which have good say objective
functions that are low with respect to
two or more criteria so if you want to
find multi objective spanning trees this
is a really simple idea so the idea is
called it's based on matching so I
called it matching based augmentation
it's an iterative construction heuristic
so you start with the MT tree and you
keep adding edges until you get
everybody connected okay and the idea is
that by looking at a certain simple
solution decomposition you should be
able to tell what the sub graph you want
to add at each iteration is so there's
going to be an interactive talk as you
can tell okay and I'm going to propose
this heuristic and I'm going to give you
the poise problem again and I'm going to
ask you to tell me what that's a problem
is
and by solving the subproblem we'll be
able to add some edges to the graph and
then by adding the edges to the graph
will actually reduce a number of
connected components we have on our rate
of forming a spanning tree by half okay
and then we'll do this about long times
and then we would have gotten a
connected graph okay so to show just a
simple illustration I'm going to give
you a login approximation for minimum
spanning tree so I start with every node
and I started the empty graph remember
it's a construction user stick okay and
what I do is while there is more than
two clusters two connected components
I'm going to just find the minimum cost
matching between any pair of connected
components so you get the algorithm so I
start I have empty graph I find a
minimum cost matching I use the matching
I get half the connected components now
I just find a minimum cost matching
between them and of course it takes only
log n base two because I'm having at
each time right and why is it the case
that the cost of the matching that I
built is that most the cost of the
minimum spanning tree this is the main
question and for this you need a really
simple observation okay imagine the
optimal solution which is the minimum
spanning tree and imagine that you have
six components currently in your
algorithm and I pick one node from each
component those are the the exes here
these are representative nodes and six
components okay now I can find a way to
match up these six nodes one node from
each component by using disjoint paths
in the spanning tree like that
okay so you really meant he join and
matches yeah yeah I never mind all that
I mean that's all just lingo but you
know this is really what I mean right
I mean I yeah fine you know it would be
a teacher as you will see in my okay so
so you see if if you give me a tree and
you give me an even number of nodes it's
really easy to pair up those even number
of nodes so that the paths between the
pairs are edge disjoint okay it's really
simple because you take any pairing and
suppose a couple of those pairings
suppose I paid this guy with that guy
and that still works okay suppose I paid
this guy with this guy and that guy with
this guy and they overlap I can just
repair them locally okay and that will
reduce the number of crossings and
you'll get to a a disjoint pair okay so
it's really simple observation alright
so now you see no matter what set of
components I have if I pick one node
from each component I can always connect
them up using a matching whose cost is
no more than the cost of these paths and
therefore the minimum cost matching I
find is that most some of the cost of
these paths which in turn is at most the
cost of the spanning tree so that thing
okay therefore at each step I'm using
cost at most the cost of the spanning
tree okay yeah I mean I don't really
need triangle inequality because the
place where I cross over from this
component because actually I don't need
it because I you know that there'll be
an edge where I'll get out of this
component go to some other component
right and that edge will connect me out
somewhere else so I don't really need
triangle inequality for this okay is
really hung up on T joints okay you get
this is a t join of those even number of
nodes in a tree if I have an even number
of components every tree as a TJ whose
cost is at most the cost of the tree
that's what he wants me to say thank you
good so now here's what I want to do I
want to use this lemma to figure out
what subproblem i should be solving for
the problem I want to solve okay so
here's the problem I want to solve
remember this is my point
so this technique I call it matching
based augmentation for obvious reasons I
also teach a lot of MBA students so
that's why I like that name okay all
right so given a graph I want to find a
tree of minimum poise one way of
defining poise is find me a tree where
you know there's more general than that
where the path length between any pair
of nodes and the tree is at most some
bound D and you minimize the maximum
degree of the tree it's the same thing
instead of summing I put a bound on 1 ok
so now suppose I want to apply MBA on
this problem what is the sub problem I
need to solve when I want to connect two
clusters ok so let's imagine an optimal
tree this is a tree where the diameter
is at most D okay and the tree has
maximum degree whatever the objective
function is okay and now I need to find
a way to connect up these components
these representatives using what I need
to find a path paths that allow me to
connect them up the parts have to have
length at most D and the degree that
they induce at any node should be at
most whatever the minimum degree is so
it's basically a path matching using
paths of length at most D where I
minimize the node congestion of the path
guys with me so this is how I I'm
proposing that we use MBA to solve
whatever problem you have if it's
possible okay which is you know you you
examine the optimal tree you come
somewhere and you've got all these
different components you're trying to
connect now this tells you what you
should do now you should find a matching
between these representatives the edges
of the matching of paths of length at
most D the objective function is to
minimize the congestion induced on nodes
by these paths that you okay that's the
flow problem right it's just a simple
flow problem saying connect this guy to
somebody else right with one unit of
flow make sure that the flow paths are
of length at most D you can write that
down and the objective function is
minimize the node congestion of the flow
you can write that flow problem down you
can randomly around it right so I've
actually just told you how to solve the
NBA pro the poise problem using a
BA because I just have to solve this
subproblem I need to find define an
auxilary graph you know where I want to
find this matching where I match
everybody to somebody else using paths
of length at most D and I minimize an
old congestion okay and you can do that
and that's what I did in my first paper
right and that gives you so this is what
you do you start with an empty sub graph
right every node is a representative
right and you iterate until you are
connected you set up this L bounded min
degree matching or min degree node
congestion problem right add it to the
solution and then continue until you get
a big tree yeah actually I think you're
not awake yeah I can solve the matching
problem in poly time yeah yeah that's so
detail we can we can do that later or
yeah but I think you guys are still not
awake yeah I'm going to write an LP for
you no I have a bunch a bunch of nodes
representatives I need to connect each
node to some other node that's a flow
problem the paths of this flow have to
be of length at most L sure I can do
that
fine okay I mean that's the detail I'll
get rid off at the end but yeah you know
poly log you know ya know in poly log
land okay think I still think you guys
have not picked up on something
important yeah what's it Michelle
because I mean if you take things that
well if the length is one okay matching
that's like it's not going to work so
what I mean so let's just think about
what I want to do if I want to connect a
representative to some other
representative okay I set up a multi
commodity flow where I connect all the
other representatives to a dummy sink
and I want one unit of flow going from
this guy to the dummy sink and I do that
for every possible node so I get one
flow per terminal and I now have to
bound the length of this flow that's all
what are you guys worried about yeah
sorry good yeah I think Sandra's awake
okay because diameter is not additive
see if I add one sub graph and it gives
me degree D and add another sub graph
from another iteration it gives me
degree another D over D over you know L
iterations or K iterations the total
degree will be K times D but diameter is
not like that because if I form a path
of length L to connect up these
representatives and then form paths of
length L to connect up those
representatives and form paths of length
L you see the the diameter is not
additive it's actually doubling so you
know this is this is broken I can't add
these paths and hope that the diameter
of the final graph but I fixed this a
long time ago don't worry okay
you just have to promote one of the
representatives up okay and when you do
that it's sort of like you you're sort
of keeping the center of this path so
instead of the center just use one end
and then pull that end up so when your K
levels up right every every terminal you
started with is that most K times D away
from
current center of the graph this is
another interesting idea so this is a
good idea for low diameter graphs if
you're trying to find low diameter
things right you connect up things with
low diameter paths you promote exactly
one of them to the next level so in the
next level the set of Representatives
you need to connect are these four guys
okay then you connect them up and then
promote one of those guys inductively
you know someone at iteration K right
will be at K times D D is the length of
one of these paths from the from the
center all right so I think that pretty
much fixes it and in the end what do you
do you actually you actually found a
bunch of these paths it's a maze of
paths you added them all together right
and you're one huge connected component
what tree do you output but remember in
the very end you have one route right
just find a minimum breadth-first tree
from that node right just find a node of
minimum diameter starting from that node
okay everybody will be within distance
log n times D from there and diameter is
a degree is additive because we're just
adding these congestions
okay and finally you've got yourself a
minimum a low poised tree okay so that
gives us this theorem okay this MBA
algorithm gives us a spanning tree where
we are within log n of the minimum poise
of what well in all my proofs I use the
optimal tree to show that my flow
problem is feasible so unfortunately my
my approximation guarantees with respect
to an optimal integer solution okay an
optimal solution from which I extracted
the flows okay so what I really wanted
to do recently was to get prove the same
theorem but I wanted to prove it with
respect to an LP
okay you might ask why and I'll get to
that at the end of the talk okay because
I needed the LP to do recursion and some
algorithm okay so but I'll get there
later I may not get there at all but
that's fine yeah okay so but let's let's
just try to figure out what the LP for
poised will be okay but maybe I should
pause here and see if you have any other
concerns on are you okay Michel with
that yeah okay all right yeah all right
okay so what's the LP for points well
it's the first thing you would think of
okay
I have degree in diameter so there are
two sets of variables okay it's really
easy okay it just looks a little
complicated but there's a variable for
which edges go in the tree okay and for
every terminal okay I'm now doing this
for Steiner tree you know I don't want
the spanning tree but it just want a
Steiner tree okay I have a set of paths
that I can use of length L remember like
I'm doing length bounded paths okay from
the tree from the terminal to some route
let's say I know a route who needs to be
in the tree okay one of the tunnels okay
so these are paths of length L from the
terminal to the route I need to pick one
of them because I'm in the final tree
right I want to be able to reach the
route from any terminal in a path of
length T at most L then what do I do
well I say the length of these these
paths that I pick okay actually forget
about this sub L it's just a set of all
paths the length of the paths I pick
should be no more than some length bound
call it L - okay so this is just average
length right okay and what is the degree
well if I pick a particular terminal
right all the usage of the paths of that
terminal should not exceed the
installation of the edge you know I can
only use a path through an edge if I
install the edge so XC is just the
installation variable on the tree okay
and the degree of a node is just the sum
of the edges incident on a node so
that's just a degree bound okay so the
degree is l1 the length of the path from
any terminal is l2 I minimize album plus
L okay so it's just a natural LP you
might say if L is long this path system
is
exponential and all of that but you know
we can fix all of that it's not a some
details okay all right so now what I
want to do is to run my same algorithm
and the same idea but I want to replace
the the performance guarantee with
respect to this LP okay so I want a true
LP rounding algorithm for poise that's
what I want okay if you all agree that
this is an LP for poise you know I just
want an LP rounding out so I just need
to make sure that the flow that I was
trying to find he's with respect to this
LP okay but this is light subtlety here
which is I don't really get flows
between terminals in this LP here all
the flow paths are going to the route
okay and they are independently all
these flow paths are independently using
copies of this X variable you see I
think some of you are starting to see
this okay it's it's just not easy for me
to start with this LP the first LP you
would write down and give me a solution
to the multi commodity flow problem
remember what the flow problem is from
every terminal you need to get to some
other terminal with the flow of one all
the paths should be of length about L
whatever your guesses okay and the union
of these flow paths should have
congestion no more than something like L
how do you get this flow decomposition
from this LP but if all of them go in
and out of the route they're using the
edges closer to the root a huge amount
of times you see if they have K nodes I
have K over two guys going up and down
the edges are getting used to the extent
K I only want to use one copy of this of
the stream
you need to show that at any point in
the algorithm right for the matching
problem there is a feasible solution
that's right that's right
from this LP that's exactly what I want
ya don't need do all wrong
what about clustering that's the same
MBA idea that might work so he's saying
like don't let two guys go all the way
to the root wherever they may just
shortcut them okay but then we still
have the mess of making sure that the
over usage of these flow edges okay it's
actually a very clean solution okay
that's what I want to tell you about I
just one slide about it okay so I still
want to use the same strategy so this is
something you all know now because I
want to use the same doubling thing I
just want to bound these flow paths with
respect to the LP this is just what
we've been discussing so far okay to do
that I'm going to use a very simple path
packing theorem okay this is a good
thing to know okay if I give you an oil
Arian graph with some terminals T okay
call a tea path there's a path between
any two distinct terminals
okay so tight we want right for a
particular I I want to go from I to
somebody else that's a tea path okay now
this is all theorem which shows that if
the connectivity from any terminal T to
any other terminal that is the think of
this as isolating cut right the min cut
that isolates T from all the other
terminals is at least C of T right sorry
okay then you can actually find a
packing of these T paths of this
cardinality okay I want to I want to
first convince you that this is actually
the maximum you can get why because
every tea path how many tea paths can go
out of a terminal at most C of T because
all the tea paths have to go to somebody
else and the min cut separating a
terminal from all the other terminals is
C of T so I can get C of T path from
every terminal T but every path has two
endpoints so I have to divide by two
okay so this is the maximum possible
number of tea paths you can get right
because you know every T maximum I can
get out of T is C of T I didn't have to
divide by two okay now how do you show
that there exists such a teapot packing
this is a beautiful example of murder
and Lois's splitting of theorem in an
oil Arian graph you can always split off
the edges incident on a vertex so that
all the other pairwise connectivities
are good so split off all the stur
terminal nodes non-terminal nodes what
do you have left are exactly DC of T
edges and then you roll back the
algorithm you get the paths so if you
didn't follow that just scratch that
okay but if you this is actually a great
if you're teaching about splitting off
you know this is actually a nice example
for splitting off thing so now you see
how I've got my paths I can't back
Steiner trees that's the problem because
I only have the solution for one tree
see my whole solution just supports one
Steiner tree how can I pack more than
one okay so let me tell you what it is
you take the solution to this poised LP
the lpv road which minimizes length plus
right and then what you do is you just
scale everything by some big number
that's what you're thinking of right so
just scale by the largest number in the
denominator then you get this multi
graph okay one becomes M so that means
every terminal which used to have one
connectivity to the root remember all
the paths had to go to the root now has
M connectivity to the root okay so now
what's the isolating cut from any
terminal to any other terminal its M
okay so now what should I do
well I have to be a bit careful because
these t paths may be really long and I
want my path to be short but we know how
to deal with that just filter the long
ones away take away the paths which are
longer than say 4 times L okay you'll
still have 3/4 of the flow left
right so you keep 3/4 of the flow okay
and then you've got all these paths
which which are T paths which start from
a terminal and go to some of the
terminal okay they are of length four L
okay and then I've got the flow packing
I need you know I basically have you
know about 3/4 flow from everybody going
to some other guy okay and somebody I
was worried about randomize rounding I
think it was you oh you always worried
about randomize sounding you don't need
land on my surrounding you can use this
old you know packet rounding result this
is like column sparsity rounding so you
know I have this path packing now the
paths are all of length about 4l okay
and the congestion by the way the
congestion at any node is only doubled
right because to make the graph oil airy
and I just had to double everything okay
so now you know I can find an actual
dependent routing of these flow paths
where the I exceed the the node
congestion by that for L here I really
do use that it of thing that's right
that's absolutely right yeah okay so
okay this may be a little fast but are
you guys worried about this okay all
right you don't see worry okay so
basically this just says I have a
solution which is a fractional flow
which gets everybody from you know which
gets a terminal T out right to some
other terminal and all these flows have
of half path links at most for L because
of my filtering I threw away paths which
are bigger than 4 L okay so now if I
look down this the set of nodes on which
I have the node congestion right the
path goes through at most 4 L of them so
the column density of any one of these
paths is at most 4 L and this rounding
method says that you know you can take
this LP solution and round it to a
integer solution where the additive loss
in every one of these constraints is at
most this is partially so instead of 2
LC I'll have 2 LC plus 4 LD in the final
integer solution okay but LC + LD is my
law is my is my LP bound so so that's it
so I got my now if you really want
details what you'll get at the end of
this rounding you
from everybody you will get one path to
somebody else okay
so now you can build this pseudo
auxilary graph where everybody has one
edge going out okay you will get some
kind of a bunch of pseudo trees like
this okay but now I can't use all of
these paths because one of these trees
may just be a long path and if I added
all of these paths I may have the risk
of blowing up my degree my diameter by
you know an unbounded amount but that's
you know if you've been following me so
far you'll probably realize that from
these trees I can either take the odd
levels or the even levels okay and then
just use one of these two paths systems
and that'll make sure that my diameter
is bounded at this point I probably lost
all of you but this about right yeah
okay yeah but basically you know the
trick that I had for merging pairs works
also when I merge these representatives
and stars because stars only increase
the diameter by two times do you rather
than just a nativity okay so I think
I've accomplished what I wanted to do
which is show you at least the main
ideas of going from the from a
combinatorial log log K to LP rounding
log K okay so now if you're curious at
all oh I'm almost done why I wanted to
do this I actually wanted to solve this
problem where I had a rumor sitting at a
node in the in the graph okay and I
wanted the rumor to go to everybody else
by phone calls so every day
any person who knows the rumor can call
a neighbor in the network and inform
that person of the rumor so in day two
both of them can get to work and spread
the rumor and in day three all four of
them can get to work and spread the
rumor okay so the problem I wanted to
solve was given a graph and a source
node under this telephone model where
you use a matching from uninformed to
uninformed nodes what's the minimum
number of steps in which I can get the
rumor out to everybody that's the
minimum broadcast time problem only one
phone call that's the telephone call
okay now if you trace how a rumor went
out in the graph in other words if you
stick from a vantage point of a node and
asked yourself how did I hear the rumor
you heard it from somebody and you
that edge into you you get a directed
arborescens and the objective function
that I am interested in in there are
Morrison's remember if that tree has
depth D it's taking that many days to do
the phone call if the if some node has
degree D I have to do these different
phone calls on different days so I get
my objective function degree plus
diameter because both of them are lower
bounds on my rumor spreading time okay
so given a rumor spreading protocol
looking at this tree that tells me how I
heard these rumors I actually get a tree
and the rumor spreading time is lower
bounded both by the maximum degree and
by the diameter okay so you know what's
a factor of two so I added them up and
that's how I got to my points problem
okay so and then you know so this was
our tree and then you know I I showed
that if you gave me a low poised tree I
could also broadcast within some factors
this is not relevant the real reason I
wanted the LP rounding is because
there's a version of this problem where
I don't care about getting the same
rumor from the root to everybody
everybody has their own rumor and they
want to tell their rumor to their mate
and some other part of the graph so this
is like the generalized Steiner version
of this problem right so you know it's
not the spanning or the Steiner versions
the generalized Steiner version
I call it multi commodity multicast so
you know it can when I make a phone call
I can actually exchange as many messages
as I want so there's no bound on the
bandwidth of the messages okay and I
still want to minimize the multi casting
time now that problem that's that's
really hard to solve this multi
commodity multicast in fact the best
known approximation for this multi
commodity multicast is this what I call
the Mary Poppins guarantee super poly
logarithmic sub X sub polynomial right
yeah
so super Pony long is that make some
polynomial yeah so it's one of those
Mary Poppins problems okay so I really
wanted to make this a poly log
approximation and I was able to do that
in this paper that I put up in the
beginning in the archived version and
two we were able to make that a poly log
for planar graphs and to get to that
poly log I needed this LP rounding
because I wanted to do
kerschen in a planar graph based on this
LP okay so that's how I sort of got into
that problem but you know for more
details about that you can read all
about it in this archive paper called
plain gossip and that's the end of my
talk and since we have an open problem
session
those are my open problems these are
pretty obvious ones I think the most
interesting one is whether we can
actually get an integrity gap of a
constant for a spanning tree where I
minimize the degree plus diameter max
degree plus diameter I think it's a
pretty natural problem that LP I don't
know the gap so that's I think the most
interesting structural problem and I
think many of you have many different
tricks up your sleeve
like things get hairy but you can't if
they are all polynomially bounded you
can do the usual you know you can make
them appropriately and so on right so I
think the diameter rates are not a
problem the degree weights create a
little bit more of an issue yeah so
that's sort of thank you
[Applause]